hello and welcome to this video playing
quattro princesses princesses mmm I've
got a minus two scoring and subscribe
check even though I'm heavy raining
favorite nobody plays Knight c3 n this
guy this and then i'll make a pre move
right peeling now great come on let's i
just play some funky stuff now don't
care and it's super annoying there is
stupid play mommy it's kind of pre move
when it is totally clear that they can
play 93 okay whatever
can you you can just take on d5 him my
rook is saying this one okay well we
should be 72 set so bad don't see it
let's dance to go for that and this is a
pre move that I can play without any big
issues yeah castleton it's a good move
how can we really just frustrated by
that idiotic pre-move I should have
thought in a little bit more him and not
get into this really bad position so I
so willingly maybe but ok just to
frustrate it about it
Joe my king is not great on the zone
Quincy form or queen bee three probably
I don't know Queen f6 is totally fine
for me check this is better the only
hope here's that can see can take or d 6
which is just good this smooth yeah
maybe this is also fine okay it's not
the best work but
that's the awful position is just too
bad it's difficult difficult to repair
c5 is also good move him when they are a
couple i mean check
the only thing is I'm ahead on the clock
yeah while playing this garbage if he
doesn't check man you have a good ending
but the likelihood of getting check made
it is pretty high good move
Joe this looks totally ridiculous but
otherwise I'll just lose the pawn for
nothing and still have a terrible
position so i should i should use the
king I'm not totally sure how bad this
is if he takes yep that's I could move
again yeah maybe a 6k me let's play a 6
& gamble here hoping that he doesn't
have anything great him Jake's King
takes I'm covering be five against
checks it was the point of a six and I'm
i had a lot here on the clock check oh
yeah he has to think about the back rank
as well Queenie fire threatens back
ranks stuff she threatening any check 27
s maybe maybe in
maybe still this move that it is just a
cheap cheap threat but it doesn't it
doesn't do much h5 this Queen d7 hmm
that doesn't help maybe okay six or
something like that I don't know a
couple of months possible I actually
totally ignored the actual check on c7
I'm really playing badly I just thought
didn't take take this into account that
he can check me okay I'm so Queen a3 now
is also also in Wow
can check on c7 Quincy 625 and win I
already was out of it again and then i
blundered blunder it away i'm pretty
sure that this was kind of okay again if
i take this what is what is this when i
try to show me show me the win there is
one but check this one okay I'm data and
I'm just blind here I don't see any move
Jay amazing really amazing game check
check hmm reminding this one check not
quite sure check still Jack don't do
nothing here queen or king up here maybe
maybe this first right check check
check check check uniform read
chick-fil-a yes oh I've no tie myself
wait for Fitz okay oh my god h5 and I
didn't see that I have no time my cell
absolutely not oh my god okay I guess
once in a while you to get lucky as well
but wow that was the worst game ever
starting from that from that from that
nonsensical primo yeah I mean c3 is the
move that is pleasure all the time and
they're basically pre-move that I
dropped dropped in this is just terrible
you just just move down now on the main
line hey I got very frustrated about
this and played this nonsense and here
I'm just saying I'm just losing an eye
opening I guess c 6 p-1 on also was
killing what okay I think he played it
he played it well enough and I am losing
so yeah yeah check the position surplus
50-something positioned the stock which
gives his go off + 55 which means
probably you see some kind of made its
plus 5 still plus this is made queen bee
three just made yeah there should be
made but somehow somehow it didn't
happen Quincy phii's made now this is
just plus five check check check check
check check check birds check me quite
cute check ya know check look these six
wins check but this this is a draw now
it's the first time I'm not losing in
this game we have seven was still
winning check yeah I Karen he had no
time he had to basically pre-move and
she I did a good job I think doing
cheering so he it's winning again Luke
g7 was winning check and th is +1 check
check yeah and this was the moment where
I recognized I have no time myself and I
just played something he played this I
could take now and and then he just had
to play me when he could play Queen g5
made anymore yeah this is the the nonsan
said sometimes happens in known
increment chairs it's sometimes not very
logical their outcomes of games okay
thanks for watching